Well,
it was incredibly unjust because they
had a hundred to one ratio.
For example,
if you had a one gram of cocaine powder,
uh,
if you had 100th the amount of crack
cocaine,
that those would be considered equal.
And I think that crack cocaine typically
has been associated with,
uh,
communities that are lower income,
poor people.
Whereas,
you know,
at,
uh,
you know,
parties in Aspen,
people aren't smoking crack.
So it did have a,
a horror,
horrific effect.
Um,
on population.
I do federal criminal work and I've seen
a number of,
uh,
young people with face horrific
sentencing because of,
uh,
their involvement with the crack
cocaine,
maybe on a very superficial level,
but because of the way the sentencing
guidelines were structured,
there is no such thing as a small case.
Well,
I mean,
they would have to have a hundred times
as much as the equivalent amount of
crack.
And from what I've learned that,
uh,
to convert powder cocaine to crack,
it's a one to one basis.
So if you were in the federal system,
it's insidious enough that if there was
proof that you intended to convert,
say 50 grams of powder into 50 grams of
crack,
it would be treated at the hundred to
one ratio.
Yeah.
Well,
I dunno if anybody anybody's destined to
be to for the criminal justice system,
but if you grow up in an area of low
income where,
uh,
where most many people are not working,
where there is,
there's not much employment where
there's not a lot of,
uh,
guidance.
Inevitably,
uh,
people,
there are a lot of opportunities to
become involved in criminal activity.
Also in the,
uh,
in the lower income communities,
people are more,
much more likely to resolve disputes
simply by dialing nine one one.
And police are more predisposed to just
simply arresting people rather than
trying to resolve an issue or see if the
issue really requires an arrest.
So you see a tremendous amount of people
that in other communities
there wouldn't have been the opportunity
to get in crime.
Uh,
things that they do would not have been
treated as a crime.
Um,
but for the fact that that's the way
that,
uh,
the police handle things,
people and people are very,
uh,
it's very easy to dial nine one one to
resolve a problem.
Well,
again,
I think it's a,
the funding,
the funding programs to,
to,
uh,
help addiction education programs to
stop people from becoming involved in a
substance,
you know,
substance abuse situations,
job training,
people that are working are far less
likely to be come involved,
uh,
in crime.
They don't have to,
to take things too to support
themselves.
So I think a lot of money would be
better spent before people get into the
criminal justice system.
Then now we,
now we spend the most amount of money.
And when I say we,
I'm talking about government in,
in building presence to simply warehouse
people.
And that's why,
uh,
this country has more people in jail
than any other,
yeah.
Per capita than any country in the
world.
And that's,
that's pretty horrific.
Well,
I still am loath to sort of to say that
someone that's committed a crime,
even if they've gone to prison,
that they're going to be like anyone
else because they're still individuals.
So I think it really depends.
Um,
there's no rehabilitation as far as
rehabilitation education.
Uh,
very little is spent on that.
Most of the money for corrections is
spent on,
uh,
protection and,
it really making sure people don't
escape,
don't have engage in violence with other
inmates.
But there's not a lot done to see that
when people get out that they won't
repeat those behaviors.
But I still think it depends on the
individual.
If they're coming out and they have a
supportive family,
uh,
they probably have a shot.
If they're coming out to nothing and,
and they had an extensive criminal
history beforehand and they're going
back to the neighborhood where they've
gotten arrested and prosecuted
over and over again.
I think there's a little hope that
they're going to turn their entire life
around.
I think towards if,
uh,
if towards the end of people
sentence,
I know in,
in,
in the federal system,
depending on what crime you were
convicted of,
they release people to halfway houses,
uh,
and conditionally released people.
So they get some sort of job skills or
trading.
There has to be something other than
sitting in a cell for 20 years.
And then on the day that your schedule
of the release,
they simply open the door for you and
give you your clothes that you came in
with.
If there's,
uh,
one would hope that towards the end of
sentencing,
some effort is made to,
to match that individual up with some
sort of preparation for the world
outside cause the world.
Not only is it different from being in,
uh,
from their experience in being
incarcerated,
but the world is different from when
they went in.
Yeah.